hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today gets you in the spirit
of christmas not with some crotchety old
guy named ebenezer or some young kid who
really wants a bb gun nope instead we
have a crotchety old guy named roger
murtagh and instead of ralphie's red
rider weapon now we have a machine gun
ho
ho
ho
today on versus it's an accumulation of
ass kicking action all-timers as lethal
weapon is taken on die hard while each
of these properties have four films
all right they made a fifth die hard and
it was not a good day at all we're going
to be focusing on the inaugural film in
each franchise although the sequels may
factor in at some point 1987's lethal
weapon versus 1988's die hard in one
corner you have mel gibson and danny
glover buddying up to take down a whole
host of tinseltown baddies during the
season of giving
in the other corner it's bruce willis
battling against the gaggle of
terrorists at la's newest skyscraper
nakatomi plaza it's not easy for any
film from the 1980s to still be relevant
today much less continue to be the gold
standard in the action section at
blockbuster video there's always rumors
that we might get a new entry in each
franchise and while both lethal weapon
and die hard's origin stories share some
dna only one movie will come out on top
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
chemistry round four franchise ability
and then we'll do a wild card round that
could involve which is the better
christmas movie well die hard takes
place at a christmas party beletha
weapon has a christmas tree drug deal
and i will take this moment to remind
everyone that yes these boats count as
christmas movies why
because i watch them at christmas
and thanksgiving and the fourth of july
you know they're really movies for all
seasons you see it's the ultimate buddy
cop film going
against cinema's favorite lone wolf
let's get it on what do you say jack
would you like a shot at the title
don't mind if i do
round one box office
for all the hoopla about these two films
celebrating the spirit of giving neither
was released anywhere close to december
with the weapon was born first arriving
in theaters in march of 1987. die hard
came a year later in a month where only
rudolph and frosty celebrate christmas
july of 1988. lethal weapon 65 million
dollar total domestic haul may not sound
like much but this was the 80s kids you
could get into a movie with two nickels
and a bazooka joe gum wrapper when we
adjust for inflation the film did 152
million dollars here in the united
states as far as the 1980s money is
concerned lethal weapon earned 120
million dollars around the globe
diehards numbers aren't much more gaudy
as it earned 82 million dollars which
adjusted for inflation equals 181
million dollars domestically and
reiterates a life lesson i first learned
from bazooka joe don't do today where
you can put off until tomorrow
especially that's making a movie because
it'll make so much more money in the
future diehard's international take was
139 million dollars but i can't imagine
much of that came by way of germany for
funsies both films had sequels that
outgrows the originals then the third
movie in the franchise outdid the second
one made in the days before you had to
have some catchy sequel subtitle lethal
weapon 2 and die hard 2 both did over
200 million dollars at the box office
then lethal weapon 3 and die hard with a
vengeance each performed to the tune of
over 300 million dollars the fourth
films also did very well as lethal
weapon 4 earned 285 million bucks and
live free or die hard did 382 million
smackers yep you heard it here first die
hard 4 is the highest grossing film in
either franchise thanks pg-13 rating as
a tiny lad with a penchant for
whatchamacallit bars and no chance of a
girlfriend i remember these film
franchises being a near-constant force
in the cinemas and for what it's worth
when i was finally able to get into a
theater to see one of their installments
i had a blast in fact 1995's die hard
with a vengeance was seen by 14 year old
mark ellis on opening day morning my
aunt took me and we all liked it so much
i went back the same night with my
parents to see it again and reiterate no
girlfriend whatsoever
come on to the coast we'll get together
have a few laughs
mark was still girlfriendless in 1998
when i made my theatrical debut to see a
lethal weapon it was part four and i
caught it opening night with my pal jess
and his family action movies they may be
full of bad words and blood and
cigarettes but they bring families
together what would become two action
franchise tent polls began as modest
hits and while i give many propers to
lethal weapon for blazing the trail of a
new kind of character-driven shoot-em-up
die-hard has the better numbers of the
cineplex and thus gets on the board
first it's one to nothing in favor of
the roy rogers fan club do you really
think you have a chance against us mr
cowboy
round two tomato meter slash audience
score there's a very good reason as to
why folks line up in droves to see the
sequels to both lethal weapon and die
hard the originals
they're really good they're celebrated
beloved and off quoted by audiences but
did all that high praise start with the
critics i suppose we have to register
you as a lethal weapon
for the weapon that would be a yes the
film that according to the rotten
tomatoes critics consensus set the
template for action films in the 80s and
90s earned positive reviews and wound up
within 80 percent on the tomato meter
maybe that's just the pallet cleanser
die hard needed because it's even higher
in the tomato patch notching in 94
that's good enough to barbecue certain
parts of lethal weapons anatomy on
hollywood boulevard so we have an a and
a b and curiously both franchises remain
fresh until their most recent outing
lethal weapon 4 is rotten but a fresh
adjacent 53
and a bad day to make a diehard movie is
rotten with no redeeming value
whatsoever at 15
jeez is it really that bad
you know what i i can't right now i'm
just it's gonna make me sad let's move
on so let's turn it over to you the
audience core voters you let your voices
be heard about these two iconic
actioners and i think it's safe to say
your fans lethal weapon is at 86 percent
here and die hard ties its tomato meter
score with another 94
the good news for lethal weapon is that
no film in its lineage is rotten with
the audience the lowest point came in
1992 when lethal weapon 3 earned a 61
percent fun fact i try to sneak into
that movie twice on two different
occasions i got caught both times and
sent packing back into the theater for
the film that i did pay to see
beethoven or maybe it was beethoven's
second i just remember a lot of dog
slobber and charles grodin yelling but i
digress die hard was a perfectly fresh
franchise with the audience until mclean
and son teamed up to defeat a carrot
chomping bad guy i really didn't make
any of that up and the fifth film in the
canon earned a team low 40 percent for
which it should be thankful it wasn't
worse
because it really should have been joel
silver produced both the original lethal
weapon and die hard and with the
directing power of a richard donner for
weapon and john mctiernan for hard that
sounded weird it's no surprise that both
movies fared well with both critics and
audiences
but once again it's die hard that sports
the better numbers on each metric and
all of a sudden with the weapon's back
is against the wall it's down two
nothing as die hard takes this round
welcome to the party pal but if we know
anything about lethal weapon it's that
when it's pressed up against the wall
that's usually when nutcase martin riggs
throws his shoulder into it to pop it
back into place steve young once did the
same thing in a playoff game all right
buddy cop legends it's do or die hard
round three chemistry
now the title of this round may seem
like it's heavily weighted towards riggs
and murtaugh our protagonist cops from
lethal weapon and after all they're the
best police brohams this side of beverly
hills cop
oh i like that for a future episode of
verses and they're playing off one
another's unique personalities that's a
major reason why but don't sleep on die
hard mclean may not have a full-fledged
partner he was teaming up with on the
30th floor of the nakatomi plaza or
sometimes the 31st floor but he did have
a ton of help
not only was sergeant al pal a clutch
arrival midway through die hard he also
provided a makeshift therapist for
mclean when he just needed someone to
talk to if ever there was a time to go
to therapy it would be while you're
picking bits of glass out of your bare
feet reginald bell johnson's lapd
officer on the wrong patrol at the right
time does it all he's comic relief
compassionate has his own troubling
history with violence and hits the most
clutch shot of the entire movie he's so
good that fans are still awaiting the
greatest shared universe stunt of them
all die hard and family matters who are
you then
just the flying in the ointment horns
the monkey in the wrench the pain in the
ass paul johnson plays a cop in both the
hit movie and the famous tgif sitcom and
nothing would be better than to see john
mcclane seated next to steve urkel at
the winslow family christmas dinner and
in die hard with a vengeance mclean has
paired up with harlem shop owner zeus
played by samuel l jackson the two pulp
fiction cast members work great together
in a movie that many considered to be a
nod or maybe inspired by or may be
written for a lethal weapon but die hard
3 isn't the only flick that might owe a
debt of gratitude to riggs and murtaugh
everything from 21 jump street to bad
boys they all took a cue from lethal
weapons formula but no one's ever done
it better than the og's martin riggs a
loose cannon whose suicidal tendency
make him both the danger to heroes and
villains he's perfectly balanced by
family man roger murtaugh who is rapidly
getting too old for this
stuff
another fun fact danny glover was only
40 years old when he first played roger
really i'm older than murtaugh well okay
he put in another good decade after that
and there's always a new crop of rumors
that he might return again so i guess i
have some time left
time is a double-edged sword for mel
gibson's rigs as each coming day brings
with it the question of whether he wants
to stay alive in one powerhouse scene he
indicates that he has his way of going
out ready wheneves and more often than
not the only thing keeping him from
doing that is the job a job that is
tremendously enhanced not just by
murtaugh but roger's family as well
later in the franchise riggs does settle
down and finds the love of his life and
renee russo's war nicole but it was
first murtaugh who found the key to
riggs's heart and helped keep him alive
in the process if the murtaugh family
unit was there for riggs then who else
besides al pao was there for john mclean
well clearly not the fbi or the
principal from the breakfast club holly
gennaro formerly known as mrs mclean
only gets a brief few minutes that end
in a war of words before it's terrorist
o'clock in nakatomi but it's also fair
to say that holly is a big reason why
jon is fighting so hard through physical
and mental anguish
and let's not forget about argyle the
limo driver who picked lieutenant mclean
up from lax gets john loose and even
cracks a few smiles as he's deep diving
into what went wrong with the separated
husband and lady maclean it's important
exposition to have because we see that
johnny he's just like the rest of us he
has the same issues and problems as we
all do and he's forever cemented as a
regular guy
riggs and murtaugh both have their own
set of internal demons to battle as well
roger wants to be there for his family
as a steady provider and has grown wary
of putting his life on the line every
day he needs a partner he can trust if
for no other reason just to increase his
odds of making it home safe each night
and martin well he needs structure a
trailer on the beach with a beer
fetching dog may be some of ours ideal
existence but riggs uses it as a
secluded way to stay stuck in his own
tragic past and it's not until he gets
some quality bonding time with murtaugh
that may involve some bad guy toe tags
that he starts to see the possibility of
a second act for his life 1988 bruce
willis would have chemistry with just
about anyone even a brief moment with
bill clay who should be on tv with that
accent because it was actually evil
terrorist head cheese hans gruber and
while it was a life-saving shot fired by
none other than ao pao from way downtown
that saved lives including both mclean's
it was riggs and murcha who saved each
other's sanity and then later lives by
becoming partners these two fellows
whose back-to-back look on the poster
sold their movies for over a decade
finally get on the board with a win here
in round three and die hard's lead has
been sliced in half it's two to one
you haven't met anybody you didn't kill
well i haven't killed you yet round four
franchise ability all right folks now
it's the time that renny harwin joe
pesci jeremy irons and chris rock have
been waiting for let's get some sequels
into the ball game but don't head right
back to the bench you originals this
round is still largely dependent upon
your broad shoulders which means riggs
is probably gonna have to pop his back
in place
i actually tried that once at home and
uh it's better left in movies no
explanation needed sure 1987's lw in
1988's dh
man am i really that lazy society went
downhill ever since we changed kentucky
fried chicken to kfc
anyway they're both still in the pop
culture lexicon for a reason they're
great movies the action the excitement
the jokes all hold up rather well and
they're both some of the best holiday
flicks you'd ever want but they also
each spawned monstrously successful
sequels tv shows and a countless number
of knockoffs yet for the next decade no
copycat flick could match the
entertainment value of what these two
properties kept churning out so which
movie set does make for the best
franchise which sequel would we want to
see next and did i mark ellis star
station screen actually invent the term
franchise ability
to me the first three die hard movies
are unassailable even the not as highly
regarded die hard 2. remember kids
that's the movie where we get snow a
really cool fire jumping onto a plane
climax and the best edited for tv moment
in film history yippee kaye mr falcon
that's actually in the tv edit they
didn't want to say mf her and i get that
but no one in the movies named mr falcon
it's colonel stewart who hijacks
airports when he's not doing naked
karate let's ask another character
played by william sadler if they think
that's the worst tv dub in cinema
history
damn light
i rest my case the lethal weapon sequels
cleverly named two three and four stayed
with the primary ingredients that made
the first one so successful riggs being
somewhat of a loose cannon and murtaugh
counting down the days until retirement
but each subsequent film added a new
spice into the recipe more joe pesci is
always a welcome comedic supplement and
getting to spend more time with the
murtaughs and a possible mrs riggs and
renee russo helps ground the action the
villains kept getting more sinister as
well and it was gently in lethal weapon
4 that added a menacing presence on par
with gary busey's mr joshua
diehard's initial trilogy probably takes
down the first three lethal weapons for
me primarily on the strength of the
villains hans gruber is an all-time
baddie and i'm just now being told in my
ear that was alan rickman's first movie
what
and major props to classically trained
ballet enthusiast alexander gudenov for
being the scariest force in nakatomi
plaza him and hans had pretty good
chemistry by the way but seeing jeremy
irons as simon peter familiar last name
was so cool he's devilishly wicked and
has a maniacal sense of timing you see
his performance in die hard with a
vengeance and you just think someone had
fun
but when we look at the mythology as a
whole lethal weapon never missed a beat
die hard kept swinging for the fences
and started striking out with live free
or die hard look i can get over watering
down some of the violence and gore and
mr falconisms to earn a pg-13 rating but
nothing really works in that flick or a
good day to
whatever maybe it's the kids as adults
and now helping aspect or the premise of
this one guy still having to save the
day or maybe we just need bruce willis
with hair to make a good john mcclane
die hard is easy to copy but as the
franchise itself grew so too did our
weariness at this one dude constantly
having to be increasingly a superhero in
these ridiculous situations that works
fine for the mcu for a dude who's at
heart just an ordinary street cop from
new york not so much kids from brooklyn
can grow up to be captain america adult
police officers from one of the five
boroughs eventually they need to pull a
murtaugh just retire and get that gold
watch
so even as i'd claim lethal weapon
maintained its greatness for longer
oddly i have more hope in a die-hard
sequel than a lethal weapon edition but
it has to be done right and there is a
script treatment offered by writer ben
troublecook that set a really cool
premise john mclean goes to japan to be
honored for his nakatomi heroics on the
35th anniversary of saving it but all
hell breaks loose and he's got to get
after it one more time i always got a
tank top on under that tuxedo instead
some of the powers at b wanted to make a
prequel to die hard and len wiseman was
tapped to direct so let me get this
straight we love a movie about a cop
who's never been in a situation like he
was in the first die hard so we'll tell
his backstory of catching purse
snatchers come on movie people
a new report has indicated that mel
gibson could direct a fifth lethal
weapon stepping in for the late great
richard donner
look the dude has been a great filmmaker
braveheart hacksaw ridge others but
let's just say he's not as universally
beloved as the guy on the what women
want poster as far as the products we've
already had lethal weapon has been the
more consistent franchise and the tv
show is surprisingly entertaining even
though it was a different rigs in
murtaugh we don't have a diehard tv show
with a different john mcclane for a
reason the format has been ripped off
countless times on the big screen
already under siege i love it but it's a
die hard ripoff sudden death i love van
damme playing goalie for the blackhawks
but it's a die-hard rip-off speed i love
it but that bus is just nakatomi plaza
on wheels lethal weapon and die hard
both have had their premises borrowed
thousands of times in entertainment
since their initial release i dare say
die hard is the more shamelessly copied
property but as a film series itself
lethal weapon had more potential for new
adventures with its original cast even
if that staying power has since been
compromised don't drink and drive kids
especially if you're leaving duke's
restaurant in malibu lethal weapon gets
the win in round four and all of a
sudden we got a tied ball game two to
two and now it's time for the wild card
round iconic moments why you gotta make
things so complicated
thanks
i don't make things complicated that's
just the way things get all by
themselves and now it's the time we've
all been waiting for the best and
baddest and most bodacious scenes
sequences and sarcastic slides from the
two films that did all of those things
better than anyone else
box office means you get sequels the
tomato meter means those sequels could
actually be good and the legacy of these
two properties proves that every lethal
weapon or die-hard film matters somewhat
even the ones that take place in russia
because why
that's the best we could have done with
die hard five
but here and now the deciding round in
today's hotly contested matchup will be
won by that first film that gave us the
most lasting memories because i'm a
softy at heart i will allow one iconic
moment from another film in each canon
to weigh in and i got some good ones but
first if you would do the honors mr j
as unhinged as martin riggs might be in
that first lethal weapon classic he
can't match the out of his mind bad guy
mr joshua how crazy is that dude well
he's doing things on camera that not
even the actor playing him would attempt
oh and did i mention that said actor is
gary effing busy the dude lights his
hand on fire doesn't bat an eye we all
had a grandparent whose fingers were
resistant to sewing needles but a
flaming appendage that's next level
stuff
diehard's carl counters with some bat
guano thinking of his own witness his
chainsaw to the nakatomi wiring as his
poor brother is rushing to finish
rigging it it was a well-planned
operation and luckily that meticulous
timing counted for an occasional
showboating moment from the scotty
pippen to hans gruber's michael jordan
as for our protagonist riggs and
murtaugh chewing it up at rogers family
dinner table is funny and heartwarming
but for my money the most memorable
sequence in lethal weapon is riggs
explaining exactly the hell that he goes
through on a daily basis he wakes up and
finds a reason not to off himself and
he's thought this plan out so much he
has a hollow tipped bullet for the
occasion he claims it's the job that
keeps him going but the sweetness of
this partnership indicates that over
time it's not the gig it's his comrade
roger that he's living for
and i'd like to thank the dog too that
pooch fetches alcohol that is a good boy
give him a treat
john mcclane also has a deep emotional
scene when he's calming down from that
initial adrenaline rush of downing
terrorists he's doubting whether he's
going to make it out of this alive he's
opening his heart over the walkie-talkie
to al pao as his feet are pouring out
blood and it humanizes john in such a
way that action stars had not been
portrayed up to that point both lethal
weapon and die hard showed us that
action stars don't have to win
weightlifting championships and deliver
quippy one-liners to win the day they
can be in touch with their feelings too
that isn't to say that john mcqueen is
short on witty comments a few of my
favorites would be welcome to the party
pal and no effing s lady do i sound like
i'm ordering a pizza
the guy's a laugh a minute unfortunately
he has a penchant for killing terrorists
with feet smaller than his sister
roger murtaugh plays basically john
mcclane maybe with a dozen more years on
him he's still up for action but he
wears his age with the classic lines
like i'm too old for this
duty you see that was a better overdub
than the mr falcon thing martin riggs is
the best shot in either film by a mile
and that's about the distance with which
he hits one of the most clutch long
reigns jumpers in cinematic history but
i also love the scene where he's dealing
with the more run of the mill sniper and
he doesn't bat an eye it's beautiful
stuff and that fight scene between mel
and gary still holds up it incorporated
jiu jitsu moves in a realistic way long
before the ufc was even a twinkle in
dana white's eye but if lethal weapon
has some great action moments die hard
plays out like
dare i utter the phrase i've utilized
before and versus one long iconic moment
it could be mclean crawling through the
air vents or his fight with carl or just
him making fists with his toes and it's
his nemesis hans who's just as powerful
from his show of force at the expense of
mr takagi to his purposely ridiculous
demands to the fbi playing right into
his hands to the shoot the glass moment
or even blowing up the roof hey you want
iconic i give you possibly the best
scene in action film history
with the weapon has a good root jumping
moment as well and we get to see how
diversion our two weed personalities
really are when push comes to shove but
there's never been anything more
resourceful desperate or heroic than
john mclean tying a fire hose to his
waist and leaping off the roof just as
it blows up the look still holds up to
this day and is one of my favorite jumps
to do off a high dive die hard is
closing in on a w but here comes lethal
weapon four into the rig i told you i
can take a moment from a sequel and for
a lethal weapon it's numero quattro it's
not the opening sequence when we get a
taste of fire in the hole from the gary
sharon era of van halen it's later when
we're in high speed pursuit on a major
la thoroughfare there's a house being
moved in the fray and riggs finds
himself concrete surfing atop an upside
down table it's a cool stunt but what
sells me on it is when he breaks a leg
off of it flings it into the windshield
of one of his antagonists i love good
improv and that is whose line is it
anyway worthy
die hard needs to match that for the
victory so we turn to die hard with a
vengeance there's tons of great action
in here too but i'm putting all my chips
into the center of the table for the
quiet chat with some agency bigwigs in a
van this is the moment when audiences
realize why john mcclane is the one in
this predicament unlike the bad luck of
every other die hard entry these
sideways events are happening
specifically to him for a reason does
the name gruber mean anything to you
peter krieg was born simon peter gruber
he's hans groomer's brother what
it's a great twist of fate and it even
engages us more in this game of cat and
mouse or simon says that we're thrust
into most importantly for our purposes
it gives die hard the win here in a
hard-fought contest that had me
wondering if i'm too old for this
you-know-what to quote doc holliday in
tombstone not me i'm in my prawn he died
like two days later die hard wins the
round and thus the match
[Music]
but it seems these days all anyone
really cares about is whether these can
be considered christmas classics the
answer is yes i'm on tv or at least the
internet and i will definitely say once
and for all that they are in the spirit
of the season of giving one could even
surmise that roger murtagh is like the
guardian angel clarence to martin
riggs's george bailey ah action
shoot-'em-ups gather the family around
the tree and enjoy loads of evil
terrorists being brutally murdered god
bless us everyone die hard edged out a
win today that's just my opinion now i
turn it over to you dear viewer vote
with your take and hit me up at mark
ellis live with your decision and be
sure to check back here at rotten
tomatoes for tons of fun lists and info
about action movies christmas flicks and
everything in between thanks for
watching this installment of versus i'm
mr falcon saying yippee kaye and to all
a good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you